it was a maiden voyage to let the world
know britain has global capability once
more after seven months at sea the queen
elizabeth aircraft carrier docking to
emotional reunions
returning home minus one jet
the ministry of defense still won't be
drawn on the cause of last month's crash
but we learned for the first time flying
was suspended after the incident
we just have to accept that doing
carrier strike operations with a fifth
generation aircraft is grown-up business
it's highly complex uh it's well thought
through
but unfortunately these sorts of things
happen and i think the thing to take
away from it was this organization was
sufficiently mature
one to understand what had happened as
best we could and we're still
investigating as we go through but 36
hours later we were flying again leaked
footage showed the f-35 toppling into
the sea on takeoff the highly classified
wreckage has since been recovered we've
now also learned the pilot who ejected
safely received medical attention
we got him off safely to go and get some
more medical care but he was great after
an addiction like that we just need to
make sure that there's no um prolonged
like symptoms that come on and but he
was great we had him overnight there was
a determination to focus on the
positives after hostile activity from
russia and a covert outbreak in the
summer the successful ejection of the
pilot without the aircraft even getting
airborne has been commended for its
cutting-edge technology the general
feeling was oh
we have an aircraft
ditched
rapid response from the command rapid
response from the flight deck team rapid
response from everybody
and that is why we drill and that is why
we train so that when these things
happen
we will be able to
recover ourselves the important uh
factor for us is that we had no loss of
life the carrier means britain can now
have an airfield anywhere in the world a
way of projecting power right where they
need it
but that capability is now clouded with
questions
over how it lost a 100 million pound jet
sally lockwood sky news portsmouth